i love bts and i was telling my manager  i was like i really want to do a song on  bts i you know i don't know what i could  do but or what what we gonna do what  song can i sing around that same time  they wound up reaching out to me and  asking me to do the better remix so i  was like oh my god look at god  being able to perform with them it felt  so good it was like so much fun like  that was like one of the performances of  all time for me that was like the best  because i had the most fun like i was  really really nervous and i was like oh  my gosh i can't believe we all on this  stage together is everybody gonna like  me like what's happening but when i got  there everybody was so excited so i was  like  shout out to bts and bcs army because  y'all show me so much love